[Music]
harrison's in boone north carolina hi
harrison welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey dr john thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
yeah so i'm pretty dead set on trying to
open up a gym in my town this year
i've got about 300 000
uh set in investments and savings
uh i'm 24 i'm totally debt free i have
no credit card debt no student loans no
car payments devil did you get 300 000
at 24 years old
uh well i've been working hard and
when i was a teenager i actually made
some really smart investment decisions
and on top of that uh you know my
grandma passed away probably a year and
a half ago and i got about 50 000 from
that
but everything else has just been
plotting and scheming along the way
honestly
wow
good for you amazing
that's mind-blowing way to go i'm so
proud of you
um so you're going to open a gym what
are you going to spend to open the gym
yeah so right now i have a budget of 100
000 but that comes down to my question
my question right now is should i bite
the bullet and and sell off some of my
investments and pay that capital gains
tax or
should i borrow against my current
investment assets and
pay that borrowed money off
you know as soon as i possibly can
you should use the money from your
investments or you should not do the
deal
okay there's two benefits to that
there's three benefits to that
benefit number one that you don't see
coming and i saw it coming because when
i was your age i went deeply in debt
buying real estate became a millionaire
by the time i was 26
okay and then lost it all because i had
too much debt um so uh uh
the the benefit that you don't realize
and i didn't realize it until i was in
my 30s because it was before then before
i started doing it when you start doing
a business investment with money
that you place an emotional value on
that's your investments it's emotional
for you to pull 50 or 100 000 out of
those investments that you've
worked your way so hard up into would
you agree with that statement
uh yeah it was yeah here's what's weird
here's what's weird is you will get
20 to 30 percent
more purchasing power using your money
than you will borrowed money because
you're a little bit pissed about using
it
it hurts more than to use your money
than to use borrowed money so you're
more careful and wise with it and you'll
get a better buy you'll go you know what
i don't need that piece of equipment
right now let's find out if this is
going to work
i'll i'll do that in my phase two
and by the way you do need to open this
gym in two phases
you don't need to just open it like you
know what you're doing because you've
never done this before because some of
the things you think are gonna work
aren't gonna work and i don't want you
spending a bunch of money on them until
you've operated the gym a little while
yeah understood um
right now i also work three jobs right
now i'm i'm a full-time realtor and then
i have two other side jobs that bring in
some extra cash on top of that and i'd
like to still be doing real estate as
often as i can while i'm operating the
gym
so i will kind of have those two
means of income coming in uh which is
kind of the entire reason i thought
about potentially borrowing the cash in
the first place i would have a mean to
pay off quickly nope if you're not
willing to put your money in it don't do
it
yes sir it's a commitment thing man so
number one is you're gonna be wiser with
the money number two is you're lowering
your level of risk
and your potential for success is
increased on the gym because you don't
have the strain of paying the note
you're 24 you made 300 000 bucks that's
unbelievably awesome i love it i'm happy
for you i'm proud of you if you burn
100k of it and you screw this whole
thing up your life ain't over it ain't
even close to over you still got 200
grand you still got a wonderful thing
ahead of you and you still got that head
on your shoulders which is actually the
secret sauce
i yeah you're right i couldn't agree
more yeah with a hundred thousand dollar
investment that's going to buy you about
seven dumbbells these days right
maybe
yeah eight eight dumbbells with the
price of gym equipment these days yeah
it's probably difficult to get this
thing funded um real difficult yeah yeah
i really would ease into this i i would
open it uh with a minimal
version one
with a plan that at six months i'm gonna
take it to version two and it's six
months more and we'll take it to version
three as a proof text meaning i prove
out some of the systems
processes marketing that you're going to
use in this thing
because opening a gym in a covet
environment is a uh it's a high risk
environment man and and buying it now
and opening it in four months is going
to put you behind the curve when people
start even joining gyms right so is this
something you can put off for a year
save a little bit more money or whatever
that looks like but
you know before it's learning the
business what percentage of people are
back what percentage aren't in your area
i'd say my guess is boone's pretty open
uh it's probably like our area we're
completely open as if nothing's going on
in our area um but uh
but you know the the uh the fear porn
that's uh surrounding corvid cova that's
out there it's being hammered out of dc
and being hammered in the media because
it's really good for the media to scare
the crap out of you all the time helps
their ratings it's kind of like tornado
warnings right
um
and so yeah you just you know you you
got all that that's the business
environment you're operating in and you
don't want to add risk to that with debt
and and you're in a high risk space
you're going into
uh i mean the number of gyms that open
and fail is almost all of them in a good
in a good year you're in a high-risk
space yeah it's like a restaurant
business it's a tough business the last
thing i'll tell you is this i i
understand your reasoning that you want
to run the gym and stay in the real
estate business
running a business starting a small
business and running it that has a lot
of hours of open to the public
uh is going to require your presence
it's going to require your focus so i
don't think you're going to be doing a
lot of real estate in the year you open
the gym
i think you're gonna be doing a lot of
gym
i think you're gonna be there a lot
you're gonna be sweeping the floors
you're gonna be setting up the chairs
and resetting the dumbbells and
sanitizing stuff and you're gonna be
doing all you're gonna be working your
butt off man
and uh uh
you know if you won't be in the real
estate business being in the real estate
business but anything with two heads is
a monster bifurcating your focus is a
good way to cause failure
so i'm going to recommend you plan on
doing very little real estate till you
get that gym up and running and it's
making so much money that you can afford
to put an operational manager in there
where you don't have to be there all the
time
but you can't do that till you get the
thing running it's up to you this is
your baby you better rock it
and um pay cash for it or don't do it
thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john deloney
is here we're talking relationships
we're talking money
john this is uh um
you know hey uh let's send him a copy of
uh if he's still on the line i think he
is sending him a copy entree leadership
and the our our our playbook on how to
run and start and run a small business
the way we run this one here how we've
grown this from a card table in my
living room to where it is today
so this whole thing of uh
a guy that ticks like that that's 24.
then amazing
that's pretty cool yeah he's a high
performance guy
yeah he's most 24 year olds in the
country don't know what capital gains
are yeah and uh uh but he's running
about three different
angles here at all times and he's done
something with the investing i didn't
get into what it was
that that worked um the danger
having been that guy
because i'm a bit of a math math is my
thing you know and so uh i was that guy
i was way ahead of the curve
when i was his age uh thus i was a
millionaire but i was 26 and i had
hundreds of properties and so forth done
probably today i think i've owned over
two thousand pieces of real estate in my
life so i mean i was early
uh
adopter or early uh whatever perform you
know or beyond my years or that kind of
thing in the early days
and uh but there's something going on
with that guy
that uh
he's not only got an abundance mentality
but he's just go there's some extra
motor running there yeah and the
challenge there is to not mistake your
past success for invincibility
always still every new job every new
project every new job
you start over with the humility at
square one and build it back up yeah
right you're learning something new
every time yeah it's gonna take twice as
long cost so much
that he learns on this one and then you
pick it up next or maybe he makes a
million dollars and crushes it man maybe
becomes the next um whatever chain of
gems it could happen i hope so for him
yeah absolutely